oran we can't do a week here without
pouring there's just porn news
constantly big-time porn star Jenna
Presley her real name's Brittany Ruiz
which they tell me she's one of the
biggest female porn stars around I'm not
quite sure from my own research she has
left the sex industry and of who's she
thinking of course Jesus let's take a
look so I got involved with the adult
industry when I was in college and Santa
Barbara I began dancing and from that
point forward a couple producers came in
and they said that I was beautiful and
that I would be great in romance movies
so in totleigh the next day and I shot
my very first scene and I felt soul
loves that day because I was puttin hair
and makeup I was told I was beautiful I
was gonna be a star and they sent my
pictures over to an adult agency who I
was with for about two years and the
rest is pretty much history I guess you
could say I don't think I've ever heard
porn being referred to as romance movies
to get you into porn it just seems like
it was a ploy right like you'd be
wonderful in romance yeah there's
nothing romantic about a gangbang I
assure you of that
all right so I don't want to be totally
glib about this because she also talks
about how getting out of the business
got her out of drugs and all the other
bad things that we all know are
associated with porn so not being
totally glib but we're gonna be a little
good because it is porn what what is it
about religion that everyone that gets
out of porn they it's always because of
religion no one seems to be able to do
it just sort of on their own volition or
their
intellect or we don't think that's true
I think that probably happens all the
time I just don't think it makes your
about it yeah I mean I think that this
is a good public interest story it's
fine I don't care
why she did it I mean because ultimately
whether it's about Jesus or whatever I
really think it comes down to the woman
right there was like a pastor there's
somebody who's involved with this church
who focuses and targets sex workers
people in the sex industry and helps
them get out of the lifestyle that could
be detrimental to them and I'm not
saying that all people in the sex
industry need to be saved I think there
are a lot of very kind of independent
sex workers who take their job very
seriously and they don't get into drugs
and alcohol and they don't have any
problems outside of that but there are
individuals who do make bad decisions I
mean there are plenty of people who have
made huge amounts of money that are
living clean lives that are married and
you know otherwise okay
so this website xxx church.com I went to
the site it looks it's a really cool
website like they got a good hip web
designer and it looks cool and there's a
community of people on there is this
like the next step for the church that
they're gonna really sort of step up
this kind of you know feel looks cool
kind of stuff to get people away from
porn because they're still hung up on
porn yeah which is why we talk about it
it's a it's a fine line I mean the last
thing I want to see is a camp a
Christian campaign you know that goes
against the porn industry
um the porn industry definitely has
problems I I personally I'm totally
happy for her that she found religion
and decided to get out of the energy
because she says that the reason why she
got it into it to begin with was because
she didn't feel any love throughout her
life and you know the church provided
the McDonald's version of love to her
and and and it works for her I actually
met a porn star once and I know I
actually I actually talked her out of
the industry like I I met her and we
became friends and she I think would
credit me as as like helping her get out
of it because she was a really smart
woman and came from a very similar
background yeah I think she had like
it's crazy she had like a master's
degree and that was part of the
marketing that the porn industry was
using here's like this really smart
woman who
like doing porn and she was with a
really big well-known porn company and
it's just sad you know like it's it's a
it's sad to see women get sucked into it
for those kinds of reasons yeah I mean
when it's not when it's not an
independent decision that they're making
when it's when it's because they're down
and out and this is a way to make some
quick easy cash but again I don't want
to although it isn't that good like we
naturally think that that's bad but it's
like you know there are strippers that
put themselves through college sure if
they don't have any moral opposition to
it but obviously she felt like her
lifestyle was kind of running out of
control and she didn't she wasn't able
to to handle the lifestyle that she was
living anymore so I think a lot of it
kind of comes down to their own personal
perception whether or not they feel like
strong and in control of their own lives
or whether they feel like they got
sucked into a particular industry but I
think that you know first of all this
whole like xxx Church and is this the
new this is not new like was it dude
Jesus like take Mary Magdalene off like
this is not a new concept right kind of
like religious people who are like
helping the poor and the sex workers and
whatever yeah this is I don't I don't
really understand why this is news right
because I think that it's like well yeah
that's what you're supposed to do isn't
that like supposed to be in your mission
and as a New Testament Christian but
isn't there something a little weird
psychologically they call it xxx Church
it sounds sort of dirty and poorni right
there so it's almost like there's see
relation I know I get it's the
initiative but there's still something
about it that sounds a little dirty like
they're still trying to wrangle you in
like none porn in the back yeah like in
the rectory I think we wrapped it up on
record I think that was sort of the
person what you can't file a rectory
with much more all right I want to thank
Cara Santa Maria and Max Lucca here and
they're on the Twitter believe it or not
there are handles are right below yeah
and oh subscribe there is a button it's
red you cannot miss it and if you're
color blind if there's a little gray box
is it gray if you're color blind would
you see red as gray Oh help me here
Simon
you don't really see it as gray you just
can't tell the difference between red
and green here's a box just click it
thanks for watching we'll do this again
next week
[Music]